apple as you can see the chief secretary
to the treasury steve barkley joins us
now minister lovely to be in the studio
this morning and
let us be fair the past 24 hours in
terms of covered news have been
worrying for an awful lot of people let
let us start
with large chunks of the southeast
moving into tier three what is the
evidence basis for that when you look at
the numbers
it does appear yep there have been rises
in and around london
but the driving fact behind this
decision appears to be the spiraling
cases in kent and essex
well it is worrying and and particularly
for those businesses many businesses
that worked so hard to make their
premises covered secure
as well and we're very conscious of that
um but if you look at the hospital
isolations which were at 25
last week if you look at the infection
rate across the board 20 percent
uh increase london as a region now has
the highest rate
of infection so so that is why the chief
medical officer
and the sage committee have had the
concerns they've had and it was
important that the government moved
quickly
to respond to that spike in infections
of course there are parts of the country
which have barely been out of tier three
or the equivalent you know for many many
months now but there will be people in
london waking up this morning going like
what was the point of the last lockdown
if within a matter of days we are once
again
seeing the restrictions increase we are
seeing businesses be
not be allowed to operate well it hasn't
been the same as previous lockdowns if
you look at the schools have stayed open
non-essential retail
continues to be open so we have sought
to respond to the concerns to enable
not just school pupils who were
particularly hard hit when schools were
closed not just in terms of their
learning but their development their
mental health
which were affected so it's been
important to keep schools open during
this period that's also important of
course for parents as well of children
at school because it impacts on their
jobs and their livelihoods as well so
so we have had to take tough measures
but at the same time looking at the data
looking at the increase
particularly in hospitalizations uh that
is what has led to this measure it
just as as regards schools given that
you've mentioned it it does appear
that the government is on something of a
collision course with city hall at the
moment
i mean can you confirm is the government
ready
to use legal measures to force those
schools to remain open those schools
which we've heard in the past couple of
days are are to be closed well i think
the vast majority of teachers has
responded brilliantly
and worked heroically during this period
the 99 of schools have been open
it is important if you look at the
advice from the chief medical officers
that we keep our schools open that is
important
to the development of children but i say
has a wider
economic impact as well there is the
issue with greenwich i recognize that
argument are you going to take action to
force the schools to open well the
education secretary being clear we want
to keep schools open and we will
look at what measures are required to do
so obviously there's a specific issue
with greenwich which has happened uh
yesterday evening
but we are keen schools will finish this
week for christmas
uh so most schools will finish on
thursday we're gonna have one more goal
i'm gonna have one more goal are you
going to use the legal methods that are
available to you to force those schools
which are closing in greenwich to remain
open
we have had so often from this
government that it is a priority that
kids remain in school
that the negative effect that you know
that many children will have experienced
because of the long period that they
spent away from school
during the first lockdown is evidence of
that so are you or are you not going to
compel these schools to open
well the education secretary has written
to greenwich to
require them to to write to schools it
is important as i said that schools stay
open of course we'll keep our
options open in terms of the legal
powers but the vast majority of schools
have stayed open the vast majority of
teachers
have worked throughout this period to
ensure that education continues
even when the schools were closed but we
do think it is important that schools
stay open that is the medical advice
from the chief medical officer and we'll
use whatever powers are necessary
uh to do so how concerned should we be
about this
new strain of uh covert 19. frankly from
the from text messages and phone calls
that i
received from friends and family
yesterday there are any number of people
who are really worried about it
i think it is concerning particularly in
respect to whether
uh the spread of transmission is quicker
with this trade i mean is there a
weakness for that because it wasn't
entirely clear from what the health
secretary said yesterday there was a
suggestion
that it might have led to the rising
cases in the southeast but
but no data was offered well we're
investigating and
you know the uh putin down are working
on that at pace we have
uh some of the best scientists in the
world uh in the uk and they will be
working on this
uh what the chief medical officer said
which hopefully will give viewers some
comfort
is in terms of the vaccine uh it would
be very surprising if the vaccine
was impaired uh in terms of dealing with
uh this virus but
uh this strain of the virus but the
concern is in terms of the spread and
whether
the increase we've seen in london and
the southeast is linked to that
particular strain and that's what we're
investigating
i do want to read you the words of em
emeritus professor of bacteriology at
aberdeen university
hugh pennington he's written in the mail
this morning there is nothing in itself
alarming about a virus mutating
we get mutations and viruses all the
time coronavirus in fact less than
others
if i were being unkind to our health
secretary i would accuse him
of having launched a new project fear i
mean at the time that the health
secretary
was talking about us all being rather
more careful as we edged towards
christmas
it does seem that this the emergence of
this new virus is being used
to make us think a lot more about the
way in which we behave i don't think
that's that's fair i'm not going to
trade
scientific qualifications with someone
as learning as that um the point is that
the chief medical officer the chief
scientific advisor
scientists at porting down are looking
at this strain there is a concern that
has contributed
to the fast spread of the infection in
recent weeks but we're investigating it
and hopefully
it will turn out to be less of a concern
than feared but the key issue
is there is light at the end of the
tunnel we have the vaccine eight hundred
thousand now
uh already of the visa vaccine uh in the
uk we're deploying that
at pace and i think for many of your
viewers that is the light
at the end of sunday that's why we need
people to continue to adhere
to the social distancing restrictions
because there is light at the end of the
tunnel
can we talk about about christmas then
in your mind
will is there any possibility that this
government will look again
about the christmas window given the
rate of infection
is where it is given that you know in
eight days time you know after eight
days of you know tier three
conditions here in london you know
hundreds of thousands of people will be
traveling to various parts of the
country
to see their loved ones and potentially
taking covert 19 with them
you can't tell me that this doesn't
remain under review but all things are
always kept under review but there's the
balance the christmas could be cancelled
is it no there's a balance to be struck
many families have not seen each other
all year
it is important for people's well-being
for their mental health we don't want to
criminalize people for coming together
sure as family over christmas
but people shouldn't misinterpret what
the guidelines say
it's not saying that people must go and
see family
it's saying that where families want to
see each other they won't be
criminalized
for doing so but it's important people
do the minimum
that is is possible so people will make
their own judgments as families will
make
their own judgments i won't be seeing my
parents uh over christmas so people
same here their own judgments on these
but we don't want to criminalize
families for coming together
and we must recognize it's been a
difficult year and many families will
want to see each other over the
christmas break i understand all of that
but it is confusing to me this morning
given that in you know 24 hours we will
be in tier 3 here in london
that the advice from government for
people in tier 3 the highest
tier let's not forget is make your own
minds up about this i mean would your
advice
to me be to travel home to scotland this
house
has always been to to the british public
to exercise their common sense which
which they have done and we've had
debates in the past as to whether every
single
aspect of guidance has been prescribed
and we've tried to
to treat the british public as grown-ups
and ensure that people deploy their
common sense what we're saying with
christmas
is people should do the minimum that is
possible but they will make their own
judgments
as families and we don't want to
criminalize families for coming together
over the christmas period but people
should exercise
the minimum that they're able to and
that's what the chief medical officer
set out
in the press conference yesterday and i
think that's what the vast majority of
families will do they'll respond
responsibly
and they will do what is right for their
families even the chief medical officer
and chief scientific advisor both will
concede that this christmas window
will lead to a rise in infection well
any social contact will lead to a rising
infection but at the same time we want
rules that are complied with
and we aren't reals that also balance
the other health impacts the other
health impacts in terms of loneliness
in terms of mental health in terms of
people that haven't seen loved ones
for a long period of time so people do
need to exercise their judgment but we
should trust people
to do so this from the the sun's
editorial this morning i think sums up
what a lot of people will be feeling
the government cannot issue scary
warnings about a new type of virus close
london and large
areas around it then let the public
loose for five days over christmas
and risk infecting the entire nation i
think they could not design
a better strategy to trigger a third
wave in the darkest debts
so i think that misrepresents the
position the position is not that we're
scrapping the tiering system for five
days that we're letting people
lose what we're saying is three for
within the family three households
can come together that's the limit
of the flexibility that is offered i
think it's been mischaracterized
as almost a tier zero that we're we're
scrapping restrictions
in their entirety that is not the case
the point is saying that
there will be families where people want
to come together with their parents
over the christmas period they need to
do so responsibly i think the vast
majority of families
will do so because they want to look
after their own loved ones
especially any elderly parents so let's
trust families to make those judgments
but it's not scrapping as that might
suggest the tiering system
or throwing the restrictions away that
is not what it's saying can we therefore
rule out a lockdown come january it
appears to me pretty much not
well we've got the tiering system
obviously we're responding
to the data responding to the infections
that's why in terms of london and the
southeast
that's been stronger but we're talking
about this from a london perspective we
need to be
very conscious that many other parts of
the country as a northerner myself i'm
conscious that many other parts of the
country
have been in these tougher restrictions
for a long period
as well so we need to get the virus down
that's why people need to con
comply with the regulations act
responsibly
but also reflect that christmas is a
special time and families will want to
come together
for that period but very very limited
period just a word before you go
on brexit i mean we almost got there i
didn't watch the end of the interview
without mentioning it
where are we this morning it does appear
still
the two sticking points level playing
field and fishing
remain the issues well those are the the
key issues and and you're quite right
they have been for for some time
uh the discussions are uh ongoing as you
know
i think you know the fundamentals remain
the same it is in both sides interest
uh to have a deal that is what the prime
minister has committed to
what the uk has set out a very
reasonable ass in line
with precedent in line with what the eu
have offered uh in previous
free trade agreements and that's what
the negotiation team
continued to work towards you your
colleague uh sergeant gales is on the
program just a little bit later on
you'll be aware that he has said look if
the prime minister does not get a trade
deal given all the promises that he's
made
million to one chance that we won't be
leaving with a deal and all the rest of
it
that he should do the honorable thing
and and step aside roger's got a point
doesn't he no i mean savage is a very
senior colleague is one i i respect uh
hugely but on this
i do uh disagree with it with him i mean
firstly
i thought you might i think many people
would i think firstly the prime minister
is battling for britain is going out to
secure the best deal and whether there
is a deal is not simply down
to the actions of the prime minister it
needs the eu
to move to respond to the precedent that
they've given
to other countries and i'm sure what you
would really respect that hey stephen
barkley love you this morning thanks
very much for being with us